while exploring the beauty of the wild
at the illuminarium you're also helping
it let's check in with rocky on safari
to learn more
i am still on african safari here at the
illuminarium before we were in kenya and
now we're in rwanda this is an
incredible experience allen thank you
for bringing it to las vegas rocky thank
you for being here you're at a
luminarium it's a place that can take
you any place
right now you're seeing one of the
rarest
experiences on earth we have brought you
to rwanda to volcanoes national park
it's the only place in the world
that magnificent mountain gorillas live
wow magnificent but endangered
unfortunately so let's talk about you
know the endangered species of africa
and how we're trying to conserve this is
a perfect example there are less than 1
000 mountain gorillas
left in the world
and we actually had special permission
for wanda to go see them so we could
bring them to you really bring them to
the world so you have a sense of how
magnificent they are but they're not the
only species endangered
lions giraffes giraffes have lost 30
percent of their population last 30
years those are just examples
wow and what are you guys doing to help
conserve these animals and help the
efforts
we're partnering with a great ngo called
wild arc a percentage of all the sales
of a luminarium go to protect the
environment that was amazing and and
besides this experience and when you
walk out or before you walk in there's a
shop that helps give back to african
communities with the sustainable gifts
too
we do the shop at the luminarium is
chock full of we actually went to africa
we met with the artesians there we
picked the works out that would give
back to their community a percentage of
those sales also go back to the
communities in africa
and really help save the environment and
those people's livelihood absolutely and
of course
while you're walking through you can
also read along you're learning you're
learning as you're experiencing and how
can people get tickets you go to
luminarium.com we're at area 15
we have three different experiences this
is one which is our wild wonderful it's
amazing
we have george o'keefe 100 flowers also
dedicated to
the beauty of the earth and then in
memorial day weekend we open space we
take you to the moon and beyond in this
room right here you'll be walking on the
surface of the moon and literally
leaving footprints on the surface of the
moon well i will be back for that alan
thank you thank you this is incredible
this is a dream i'm just going to sit
down and enjoy it you guys got to come
down i'll send it back to you